how do you get a sitter to to to give
you a pose that you like it took a lot
of time you know it's it
it deals with trust and how you gain
that is like giving something from
yourself to to the sitter you can't
always take take take
what have you found is the best way to
make money as a filmmaker
get
involved in anything that's possible
that will help you get better as a
filmmaker whether it's editing
um peeing writing
on shoot
um
taking any job
any job because that helps you as a
writer be a security guard be a bus
driver be on
amazon prime delivery
because you're building
different experiences and you could
write about that
um and still have a living
and
there's only until you reach that
kind of threshold where you can make a
sustainable career with with with your
art or with your filmmaking but when
you're starting out
you take as many jobs as you can
teach if you can um uh
teaching helps you know uh any any kind
of thing so
i think you just have to hustle
hustle find any job
um
survive pay the bills
and that if you can do that that
actually teaches you
how to get a film made because it's not
getting a film made is the exact same
way because it's not easy you know you
have to use every little ounce of your
creativity your your experience your
inexperience
just combine it on and will will it will
it to happen so
if you have to uber drive for two months
um so you could write for two months
you have to make those sacrifices
what was one of your best part-time jobs
that really helped you actually be
creative and then maybe what was one of
your worst
uh being a
being
i always said the
two things that made me
become a better photographer not a
filmmaker photographer was being a
waiter
and being
um
a wedding photographer
you see
people at their worst it's like if you
can handle that if you can handle the
pressure
of those things
uh
that
that would help i think it's it's it's
like because you know what happens
plan a never works i was playing b c and
d so
if you could get that in your your your
dna and your bloodline to always have
plan d ready um that's
what i found filmmaking is about is
adjusting you know adjusting um
so the job that i learned was because
you know how to read folks
read people if if they're happy with the
food or not food or if they don't want
you to come near their table
um those are those are great instincts
to learn so when you're making a film
are you giving the actors enough space
or do you does this person need more
direction this person doesn't need any
direction you have to know each does
this crew member need that do we need to
sit down so each one you have to read
people differently and under stress
stress is caused by
lack of time and lack of money so that's
what happens in filmmaking so people get
it's like bees running around like ah
so if you know that's going to happen
and
and immediately find the solutions um
so
they say never let them see you sweat
but
i try not to let people see you know me
all riled up but i'm also crying in the
inside and i just
i'm just smiling through but um
but being a waiter helped me doing that
you will learn to think on your feet
yeah any customers any kind of customer
service
thing um
your second part of the question what
what job that i didn't like or
yeah well i mean um what was maybe and
maybe they're the same ones that was the
toughest because i was wondering what
was one that actually helped your
creativity which sounds like learning
how to read people
yeah the other two
uh yep it's being empathetic that's why
you know any job that could could get
you feeling what the other person is
going through the more you can do that i
think that will help with your writing
they'll help with your direction
you you're producing skills because once
you kind of
could train yourself to walk in other
people's shoes
you gain empathy different perspective
and then you you gain um an
understanding it might not always be the
right understanding but you gain a
different perspective so you don't be so
narrow-minded on your particular review
and um i think that start then that that
breeds creativity you know that's the
spark that kind of
whoa
now i could create this because um
this person feels that way you know um
you you try to get all that energy and
form something yeah
yeah and maybe to um learning how to
de-escalate a situation and so whether
you're working in food service or you
know at someone's wedding or supermarket
there's going to be people that either
going to try to test you or they're
really angry and just learning how to
de-escalate before the blow-up
exactly i think i think that's it that's
a it's a it's a skill you know i i was a
portrait photographer
and
to get someone
to trust you to to relax to
to get you to do what
you want
or them uh what how how do you get a
sitter to to to give you a pose that you
like it took a lot of time you know it's
it it deals with trust and how you gain
that is like giving something from
yourself to to the sitter you can't
always take take take
so that i take that on
with me working with people with with
with the crew you know we talked about
how can i help how can we help you what
could i tell of myself that would make
me vulnerable and um for you to
you know
for us to gain that trust and that
respect because
uh i think that that is that's important
that's important that's important um
you know
just important way to treat treat your
neighbor this is with respect and you
want to understand how what their life's
about
and i like that giving of yourself while
you're on set so if you have an actor
that maybe
you know they can deliver but maybe for
whatever reason it's a tense situation
and you're not sure why
i mean you know that was it another
person we interviewed talked about sets
being pressure cookers
and sometimes there's personalities on
sets whatever it's just
getting that person to feel comfortable
i like that giving
yeah and that's and it and that takes um
it's like chess it's like two three you
have to think like two or three um steps
ahead you know like
um
and
i hate to say it's like almost
knowing
the situation
and how to diffuse it or manipulate it
and calm things down if you want someone
riled up
what would get someone riled up if you
need that reaction if you want someone
in shock
like this this is an interesting story
i forget who the photographer was but
they had to do um like um
a shoot of let's say
uh i think it was like the queen of
england or something like that right and
then they're like oh she always gives
the same look
how you want something different um
so
they were shooting at the end was like
oh she she knew
like the queen was like a dog lover or
something at the end was like oh
how how
how was your ride here and she was oh it
was great until we ran over a dog and
then it clicked you know and then so
it all these stories and when i was
younger i was naive to think like
photography is the truth but no there's
three truths your truth my truth and the
truth so if i wanted you to to pose a
certain way
you know if i want to light you in a
the sinner would never know
you know it's so it's so odd to me
to that power later like oh you could
kind of manipulate light
and
story
differently so
i try to hold that kind of um
that kind of like knowledge kind of
precious in terms of like
understanding and and and one
like if we're on the same page and this
scene is about pain
how can
how do we go there and you need
some extra help
on that um that's where i think i could
come in and maybe help and go
let's talk that out or maybe we don't
need to talk about that out just feel it
just let it rip you know so
each actor is totally different the same
with working with a dp
um
you you got to trust
each other that's why it's fun being a
director you hire you work with people
because they know what they're doing
you just get out of the way and maybe
just like could you try it this way and
they're like okay
you know it's it's easy now it's it's
like you for me
i
i because everyone who you're working
with you i trust them to just do their
what they're there to do and and that's
the best part you know um i think that's
where
magic happens
and just going back to when you talked
about working at weddings yeah and they
can be pressure cookers too sometimes
it's not actually the bride that's the
problem it's the family oh yeah it's the
family you know
did you make sure did you get that you
know oh were you a wedding photographer
too because i got that same thing this
uncle was like i've worked yeah yeah
like
i i got about 300 photos of them
twirling you need another one yeah i got
you know but again it's the client and
your clients are always right and you
gotta like suck it up but
i did 14 weddings and that was enough
that was enough for me and i knew um
that's that skill set is totally
different you know it's it's definitely
great and there's some great wedding
photographers out there um i think um
you know i got a glimpse of it and uh
remember i told you i was a quitter i
quit all the time you know so i quit
when photography
yeah
when did you know it was right was it
the last one
when i had anxiety
and going i don't want to do this
anymore so um
i think when you have that feeling of
like
i think it's like i made a point if i
and
if it felt off
um i'm gonna try my best not to feel
that bad you know even if i have to get
another job and become a floral
assistant um
whatever it is um i didn't mind going
backwards um
because i didn't think it was going
backwards i think it was safety you know
um in terms of um i want to get used to
to being where
where
i want to be i didn't know where i
wanted to be i knew i didn't want to be
that remember we talked about like i
knew what i didn't want to do and
i didn't want no i i want to be a
filmmaker and that was like only until i
was 35 years old you know i didn't know
that's
that's that's the path so
um
so when i would quit when when um
it didn't feel right
and for too long i just didn't want to
waste
a year or two years being somewhere i
didn't want to be
you know weddings are tough for almost
like high school reunions yeah there's
there's a lot of ego and sometimes it's
not coming from the writing room yeah
yeah and and um
and there's certain there's only a
certain kind of
um
you know i'll be in a church and
the photographer is not allowed to use
their
flash but everyone else is allowed to
use their flat and i'm like oh i can't
eat it so but that's minor i enjoy i
value the 14
weddings
it gave me that
learn how to deal with pressure and
because you've missed the moment you
don't go back to another i do you know
hey can we um take two uh let's let's
take let's do another take and like
that was it sir um so
uh if you get used to that pressure um
and the pressure to uh
it's okay if you do fail because what's
the worst thing
for me the worst thing in life is to die
so
yeah when i if it's not going to kill me
i could survive it you know um
i might not pay rent the next month but
i could survive so that that would i
just tricked my brain
to um
to do weird things
you